playing with dolls you didn't actually
read the entire hadith did you
how stupid do you look
so this fake ex-muslim now atheist
is mocking this sister because the
sister says that
in the hadith that says that aisha and
radiohanna was playing with dolls
so she's trying to say no she was a
little kid basically
and it was a big flop so she was trying
to mock the sister
but it backfired when i came into the
scene here is how it went and it just
shows you the
arrogance and the ignorance absolute
ignoramus
these people are and they have no idea
about the religion and they say they
left islam
with this kind of level of intellect no
wonder you left let's watch this video
guys
enjoy it because it gets entertaining 12
13 14 15 gonna be doing besides
playing with dolls what uh-oh you didn't
actually read the entire hadith did
you you would have seen that at the
bottom it says the playing with dolls
and similar images was forbidden
but it was allowed for aisha at the time
as she was a little girl
uh oh i don't even think you know how to
read a hadith because that sister was
right because what you're reading and
you think is a hadith is not there's
brackets there
brackets meaning it's not a part of the
hadith it's a commentary of someone else
and if you notice at the bottom it calls
fatalbari a commentator of hadiv ibn
hajjal askalani if you go there
is imagine ascalani says that this was
at the battle of
haibar and at the battle of
her was 14 years old
how stupid do you look peak oh and by
the way got done two videos refuting
this very topic itself